déclaration
particulière de la ministre duran-sauve
à nos collègues de nouveau voici ce
qu'elle a dit la ministre Duran show au
sujet du fait que on enlevait peut-être
des droits au locataire tu peux pas
utiliser un droit qui est pas le tien de
céder un bail quand c'est pas ton
immeuble et c'est là que ça fait mal le
locataire qui veut faire ça qu'il
investisse en immobilier donc il devient
propriétaire de son logement pour
pouvoir avoir plus de pouvoir sur la
façon dont les choses sont faites
aujourd'hui entrée du Conseil des
ministres déclaration de Madame
Duranceau qu'on écoute
j'ai dit ça je suis désolé mais ça paru
insensible dans une description
juridique et économique des choses alors
au contraire je suis très sensible à ce
qui se passe en matière d'habitation
très sensible mais la raison et la
raison quoi
je sais que c'est pas politiquement
correct mais c'est vrai
ce qu'elle a dit c'est quoi le problème
avec ça
non mais les gens non je comprends que
politiquement elle peut pas dire ça mais
les gens qui ont pris un risque une
hypothèque qui ont qui ont acheté un
appartement ou élever leur famille et
avoir un petit peu un petit revenu
additionnel pour payer leur hypothèque
puis ils ont acheté un quadruplex à Parc
Extension ils ont payé 500 000 ou 700
000 mais ils ont décidé de prendre le
risque puis si tu es pas capable de
payer leur hypothèque mais vous savez
quoi la banque aurait pris leur immeuble
parce qu'ils ont pas payer leur
hypothèque si le gouvernement veut
contrer l'enjeu des des du monde de
logement qui investissent davantage dans
les logements abordables qu'ils
construisent qui prennent le risque
d'investir et de construire ses
appartements pour du logement abordable
mais quand quelqu'un est propriétaire il
a un locataire ce locataire paye ce
qu'il paye le loyer ne peut pas être
augmenté au-delà d'un pourcentage qui
est déjà prescrit par année mais une
fois qu'il décide de quitter son
appartement il peut pas passer son son
son bail à quelqu'un d'autre la
propriété appartient aux propriétaires
qui a pris le risque et qui a pris le
risque de potentiellement pas être
capable de payer son hypothèque et la
banque allait prendre son immeuble donc
là il y a aussi oui il faut se soucier
des locataires mais aussi il faut pas
perdre que la propriété ça appartient à
celui qui a pris le risque ok là Dimitri
Françoise puis Jean-François qui gigotte
sur leur chaîne
de famille je parle de famille qui ont
pas beaucoup d'argent qui ont acheté un
petit triplex sur un quadruplex à Parc
Extension ou à Saint-Léonard puis on a
le gouvernement va arriver leur dire
voici ce que tu vas charger à partir de
maintenant puis si quelqu'un veut veut
donner son bail à quelqu'un d'autre que
quelqu'un d'autre va le donner à
quelqu'un d'autre
on peut pas avoir le gouvernement
partout dans nos pattes ça prend son
rez-de-chaussée de notre maison ok
François
de la ministre j'aime ça réplique
d'aujourd'hui
a fait ça la musique elle regarde
quelque peu et puis ça Metropole sur le
cœur de ceux qui ont senti que faisait
juste tourner le faire dans plein parce
qu'on vaincu que beaucoup de gens qui
aimeraient ça beaucoup de jeunes qui
aimeraient ça pouvoir posséder un
immeuble et pouvoir le louer de gens
plus âgés aussi mais ils ont juste pas
les fonds mais ceci étant il faut aussi
se rappeler céder un bail je sais pas si
vous savez juridiquement quand on baille
se termine te plus rien tu as plus de
droit là on n'est pas dans ce cas-là
céder un bail c'est quelqu'un qui est
encore en cours de bail puis qui dit moi
je veux plus garder ce bail là je veux
sacré mon cas peu importe la maison et
voici je t'amène un nouveau sous
locataire et là ça ramène la situation
juridique dans tout ce que la ministre
fait moi je trouve que tellement on
explose tellement sur quelque chose qui
devrait même pas être le cas c'est pas
dire que le propriétaire prendra
peut-être pas le sous locataire suggéré
par le locataire parce que techniquement
le locataire que signé pour un bail par
exemple d'un an dans huit mois dire je
sais que mon camp et je n'ai aucune
conséquence il peut trouver un
sous-locataire pour prendre ses droits
et obligations ce que la loi vient faire
c'est qu'a dit au propriétaire tu es pas
obligé de le prendre avant il était
obligé à moins d'avoir un motif
absolument incroyable et le fardeau
était assez énorme sur ses épaules alors
moi je trouve qu'on joue un peu dans la
sémantique l'idée de céder le bail
François c'était pour éviter une
augmentation
abusive du loyer aussi pour le prochain
locataire ça peut
être ça
que la personne veut pas continuer son
bail tout ce que j'essaie d'expliquer
c'est que différentes raisons et ça
c'est parfait tu t'en vas ailleurs je te
trouvais quelque chose de mieux et ça
fera ça va faire en sorte que le
propriétaire si on me dit le
propriétaire peut l'empêcher de s'en
aller là je dois dire mon ami tu veux
augmenter ton loyer ben trouve-toi un
autre un autre une autre personne que
moi pour pour l'assumer on est loin de
la demande de la lettre signée par tous
ces gens-là se collectif qui dit c'est
l'offre de logement qui est le réel
problème au Québec je pense qu'on est dû
pour une espèce de sommet de du logement
pas nécessairement d'habitation mais un
sommet du logement pour ramener tout ce
beau monde là ensemble pour pouvoir
trouver des solutions à long terme il a
manqué 1000 semble-t-il des logements OK
alors madame Duranceau qui était
relativement peu connu commence à faire
monter sa notoriété et d'ailleurs ce
matin sur Twitter il y avait un de ses
premiers même vous avez un même c'est
une photo qu'on détourne et le même
c'était madame duranso son visage sur le
portrait de Marie-Antoinette pourquoi
parce que Marie-Antoinette est devenue
célèbre pour une phrase qui semble-t-il
elle n'a jamais dit mais en tout cas on
lui attribue et c'est au moment juste
avant la Révolution quand les Français
disaient il y a pas de pain il y avait
une crise du pain et elle a dit qu'il
mange de la brioche parce que elle tous
les jours devant elle il y a du pain
puis de la brioche
à manger la brioche qui coûte plus cher
à quelqu'un évidemment ça montrait
comment elle n'avait aucune idée de la
réalité des gens c'est ça que ça voulait
dire alors pourquoi est-ce que ce même
est très pertinent c'est parce qu'elle a
dit hier
les locataires qui veulent faire des
sessions de bail ils ont juste à
investir dans
de la brioche s'ils veulent pas être
locataires bon alors
ça renvoie exactement à l'argument que
je fais souvent ici que les élus les
députés éliminent s'ils sont trop payés
ils sont trop éloignés de la réalité du
monde madame durant saut d'ailleurs la
majorité des membres du Conseil des
ministres acquises viennent de
l'entreprise sont des cas supérieures
madame Duranceau vient d'avoir une
augmentation de salaire de 70 000
dollars faut se dire ça là ok alors donc
elle ne comprend pas la réalité des
locataires dont la majorité gagne moins
de 50000 dollars par année puis paye à
peu près 20 000 dollars de logement
alors le 30000 terrestre il pourrait le
mettre dans l'immobilier il pourrait
aussi décider de nourrir leurs enfants
et de leur acheter des vêtements bon ça
c'est la réalité alors c'est pour ça que
je trouve que cette déclaration est
extrêmement
révélatrice de la distance
entre madame Duranceau et les ministres
qui ont adopté sa réforme et la réalité
des locataires bon maintenant vécu ça ce
qui est bon un petit piqure de rappel de
réalité elle ne va pas répéter ça même
si elle le pense il y a effectivement un
problème et je l'ai dit hier j'ai pas de
problème moi avec cette modification sur
la session des baux si et seulement si
il y a tellement de choses dans la
réforme que le rapport de force des
locataires et largement renforcés puis
moi je tiens à dire pour la en toute
transparence j'ai été locataire pendant
très longtemps et maintenant je suis
propriétaire alors il y a trois
logements que je loue je fais du
renouvellement de base je fais des
rénovations etc alors je vois des deux
côtés de la de la de la médaille et je
sais très bien que mon rapport de force
depuis trois ans et beaucoup plus fort
qu'avant et si j'étais pas un bon
propriétaire je pourrais je pourrais
forcer la note voilà donc c'est avec
votre mirabolant salaire de députés que
vous êtes devenu propriétaire exactement
j'ai vendu une coupe de livres aussi
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI